welcome back to hannity the white house
is still reeling from senator joe
manchin torpedoing the buildback better
plan and now former president donald
trump is speaking out saying this is a
good thing for the country and for biden
as well he told foxnews.com quote
i think that mansion is actually helping
biden from himself
because if you look at it and you look
at what was potentially going to be
passed and i'm not saying it won't maybe
he'll change his mind but it would blow
this country up with inflation
and with other problems
unfortunately that doesn't mean the
white house and far left progressives in
congress are ready to let it go some are
even calling on biden to take executive
action to keep parts of the plan alive
here's what jen saki said earlier today
but our objective and our focus now is
moving forward both of our relationship
with senator manchin and our efforts to
get bill back better done to have
discussions with other members of the
democratic caucus and we're going to
spend less time looking in the rearview
mirror and more about looking forward
and biden told abc news tonight that he
isn't giving up on buildback better so
what will the new year bring joining us
now with reaction is tennessee senator
marsha blackburn
senator thank you so much for joining us
tonight on hannity we had the pleasure
and i had the pleasure and honor of
serving with you and when we were both
in the house of representatives um
donald trump made an interesting
observation and that is that
joe manchin probably saved joe biden
from himself what's your reaction to
that
i think he may be saving some of these
moderate democrats who are desperately
looking for a place to land and what joe
manchin has done is to say okay there's
the joe manchin wing of the democrat
party and then there is the joe biden
pelosi schumer aoc the squad wing
of the party but here is what we do know
jason the buildback broke blow up as i
like to call it
is something that has rocked washington
they did not get their way the american
people have rejected what they are
offering
in west virginia this is wildly
unpopular so then what do the
celebrities in the elitist do
they start demeaning and disparaging the
people of west virginia for having an
opinion and wanting to protect their
freedom and with disagreeing with the
leftist socialist wing of the democrat
party
so i i think that all of this together
is making a very good environment for
the republican candidates in 2022.
yeah it's a really interesting because i
i don't know why they just went to such
great lengths to disparage senator
manchin and the residents of west
virginia they still need him on every
single vote moving forward and i don't
see why joe manchin continues to put up
with that i think the democrats will
pass something though out of
reconciliation they can't let that tool
pass them by without passing something
what do you think that's they're going
to try yeah they're going to try to do
something i think the problem they have
now is the american people realize this
is a socialist agenda and the american
people realize the democrats are trying
to take one vote take control of your
children their education of your bank
account your small business force the
green new deal on you and people are
tired of crt they're tired of
federalizing elections they're tired of
crime in the streets and what they're
looking for
is to get their freedom back and you
know what they're really tired of
inflation and passing the bill back
broke bill would make inflation worse so
i think every day that passes jason
they're going to have a more much more
difficult time when you're going to the
grocery store shelves are empty you're
going to three or four grocery stores to
get what you need for christmas when
your gas is up near 350 four dollars a
gallon i mean they are losing ground
fast you can look at all the polling the
economics the security of this
people have said no we gave you a shot
you have dropped the ball we're done
yeah they acted as if they had some
massive left-wing mandate and they did
not they never did we should have
listened to bernie sanders when he said
that joe biden was going to be the most
progressive president ever
senator blackburn thank you for joining
us tonight on hannity and merry
christmas to you hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else